el presidente mexicano arremete contra
sus críticos nos acusa de exagerar sobre
la violencia que atraviesa el país y
decirle al pueblo de mexico que estén
tranquilos que hay gobernabilidad hay
estabilidad y al mismo tiempo
hay
un interés de nuestros adversarios
los conservadores
de magnificar las cosas el jueves de la
semana pasada un mortal enfrentamiento
en la cárcel de ciudad juárez entre los
chapos miembros del cártel de sinaloa y
el grupo local los mexicles que dejó un
saldo de 20 muertos el 9 de agosto el
ejército atacó a una banda criminal en
los estados de jalisco y guanajuato en
donde hubo un muerto y cinco detenidos a
pesar de este panorama violento del
ejército dice tener éxito en el manejo
de la situación como la estrategia de
seguridad
va avanzando dando buenos resultados
pues
las organizaciones van buscando como
cómo hacer para poder pues distraer
inclusive a las fuerzas de seguridad
pero para los activistas y víctimas de
la violencia las circunstancias son
otras y pidieron a la onu que declaró un
conflicto armado interna en méxico que
vivimos en un estado terrorismo en gran
parte del país y como el gobierno no lo
quiero recorrer conocer estamos pidiendo
algo
en esta carta que reconozca oficialmente
que méxico está involucrado en un
conflicto armado interno este fin de
semana las cifras de homicidios en el
país fue de 196 una cifra destacada por
el gobierno ya que es el tercer fin de
semana con menos de 200 muertos
violentos en lo que va de 2022